Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa
homage to the Buddha, the blessed noble and fully self-awakened one.
So, we've come to the end of our three-week retreat.
Some of you have been here for three weeks.
Some joined a couple of weeks back and one or two of you came this week.
So as usual at the end of a retreat, there's this translation, you might say, of what we've come to understand in our practice into our daily life.
And one of the things the Buddha did was he left, I want to start with the monastic order so you have some idea.
He said that he had left the Dharma and the Vinaya.
He didn't just leave the Dharma, which would be the teaching, the practice of meditation and all that.
He also left the Vinaya.
The Vinaya is the rule of the monks.
And he considered that of equal importance, the Dharma and the Vinaya.
And he obviously saw that the institution that had developed around him was of importance as maybe not so much...
to maintain the teaching.
I'm sure that was on his mind, but as exemplars.
So as the order grew, especially after the first 20 years, when it seems people joined who were not of the same caliber as the first intake, these rules began to appear, all sorts of rules.
So there were serious ones for which you lose the robe,
such as stealing, any, if you excuse, any sexual penetration to the depth of a mustard seed.
Very precise, very precise.
In any aperture, by the way.
So you can see he's got it really taped, you know, there's no way out of it.
And then there's all sorts of rules about behavior between monks and especially women and for nuns with men.
And there's what you might call institutional rules, which define the institution and those rules which are really to do with morality.
And they're all mixed together, which is rather interesting.
It's actually a very...
illogical code it's really to do with the punishments or that's not quite the right word in buddhism the consequences of what happens if you break these rules so the rules come in in the measure of their
of their consequence.
So the ones I've just mentioned, you lose your robe.
There's no ceremony for leaving.
You don't have to go and make this great confession in front of thousands of people.
You just disrobe, you just disappear.
That's if you can handle the shame and the horror of being a monk, having broken these rules, of course, you carry on being a monk.
But that would be very hard, I think.
But there's others which demand a meeting that you have to tell what you've done.
Like, for instance, an obvious one, touching a woman in a lustful way.
You have to confess to five and you have to be separated for at least six nights.
And then you have to get 20 monks to get you back into the order to reestablish you.
unless you're out in the cold.
There's others where you have something which you shouldn't have and you have to give it up.
So, you know, I don't know.
For instance, sometimes monks will buy something
But it'll be like, say, the scriptures.
But because they bought it with money, it's not to be had.
So often you have to give that up.
But often that's given back to the person, you see.
It's just like a reminder, really, that they shouldn't be doing that.
Then there's all sorts of little rules.
And then we get down to, and I'll just show you how nitty gritty it is.
And I don't know...
And the Buddha said to Ananda, look, these lesser rules, you can get rid of them, you see.
Well, of course, Ananda didn't ask what he actually meant by these little rules.
So he was heavily blamed at the council.
So nobody's ever had the gumption to say, well, look, you know, we can get rid of this rule.
But he gets down to this, you see.
And just note the difference, even though they're all just put in any old order, not making a distinction between what is moral and what is institutional.
So you get one which is, for instance, I shall not look enviously at another's bowl.
So when you're sitting there at table, have you sort of peeked over and thought, look at that, how could he take so much?
So it's looking, the envy of looking at somebody's food, you see.
But then you've got things like what you might call just etiquette.
I shall not eat stuffing out the cheeks like a monkey.
You see, I shall not make a chapu chapu sound.
And I shall not eat making a suru suru sound.
So there's all these bands of rules about behaviour, you know, which all really have to do with a certain etiquette.
And I suppose you've got to ask yourself, why?
You know, why such a...
why such a finickity-ness about things, you see?
So the only way you can explain that is the way the Buddha talked about himself.
He said, who sees the Buddha sees the Dharma, and who sees the Dharma sees the Buddha.
So in other words, your behavior is a manifestation of your wisdom.
And there's something about somebody who is
awakened or liberated, whatever, however you wish to name it, that there's a certain dignity about the person, a certain way of behaving which suggests a refinement.
So this whole business of ethics, and we'll
we'll talk about why it's so important, is moving from the gross, you know, like finally we've come to the end of killing people, thieving from the next door neighbour, you know, and swearing at them.
And we've sort of come away from all that.
But there's a whole section of behaviour which is a refinement to do with the beautiful mind.
So we're moving towards beautifying the mind and this naturally expresses itself in the way we behave.
Now, to go back a step and wonder why ethics is so important, remember the sequence of events in daily life.
There is always this underground ignorance, right?
Now, remember, that's the wrong word, really.
We should say not knowing.
In fact, I did find the right word, nescience, but nobody knows it.
So I thought, there's no point in using it.
Every time I say, translate avidya, I've always got to do this sort of double take on it and say, well, it's not culpable ignorance.
It's just, you don't know.
And then there's the mistake we make.
What is the mistake we make?
The mistake is to think we're human beings.
See, once you realize that, that is a conventional reality, right?
I mean, we're not apes, right?
But in an ultimate reality, we're not human beings.
We're not this body, heart, mind.
That's what I mean when I say human being.
So having made the mistake of wanting to be this, believing ourselves to be this human being, what is it that we really, really deep down in our, in the most deepest recesses of our, what do we want?
To be happy, isn't it?
You just want to be happy.
And you can define that in any way you want.
For some people, it's money.
For some people, it's love.
But basically, we're all searching for this happiness.
Now, our mistake, of course, is to seek happiness in the sensual world.
And that leads us into three relationships which are undermining our sensuality.
even though sometimes it doesn't seem like that or feel like that.
So the first one is, of course, that you generally feel more happy the more you have.
And more is a noun, just more.
So more friends, more money, better job.
And it just goes more, more, more.
And what we don't realize is that the more you have, the more vulnerable you are.
Because the more you have, the more you have to lose.
And the more you have to lose puts you into a state of fear, a state of anxiety.
And this anxiety, of course, is underlying all our pleasures in life, because we know that it could all disappear in a trice.
In fact, the news is now that the world is going to dip again into a huge recession, it seems.
So a lot of people are going to lose work.
There's going to be misery out there, is it?
Hopefully it doesn't affect you, of course.
So and on top of that, of course, there's this aversion, there's this defense mechanism where anybody that is undermining your possessions is to be seen as an enemy and must be must be annihilated at all costs.
So you can see that these three these three
dispositions relate to show us our relationship to the world we're either acquiring something or we are defending something or we're running away from something hiding from something so from these three dispositions all our negative all our unwholesome actions arise and
you know, the greed, all the hatred and the spite and the revenge and all the other side too, the anxiety and the depression.
It's difficult to define depression these days.
People seem to have various definitions.
But when I personally talk about depression, I just mean those feelings that you have
when you get in contact with something in your in your in your makeup which um is trying to come up but you don't let it out so you're having a clue what it is it could be suppressed grief it could be suppressed fear whatever it is but as it comes up as it tries to surface there's an unwillingness to go there and there's a fear of it because you just don't know what's uh what's
you know what turbulence that is in the heart i mean that's one of our big problems in meditation is to is to get that um to to be able to to go into the into the bonfires and and to feel comfortable there you know not to be not to feel you know burn up with them so
These three dispositions lead us then into these negative actions.
And because of that, we have the consequences that come of it.
Technically, it's called vipaka, karma.
Karma is the act, vipaka is the product.
But these days, of course, it's become in our language to talk about your karma.
Anything that happens to you is your karma.
Just on an aside there, we need to be clear about what personal karma is.
Your personal, by which I mean that karma which is preventing us from achieving liberation, are these dispositions within us, which every time we act upon them get worse.
That's our personal karma.
What happens to us from the outside could be caused by a myriad reasons.
The Buddha is quite clear about that.
Just because you catch a cold doesn't mean that's because you pushed somebody out in the snow many years ago.
It just means somebody sneezed at you and you got mad.
So, I mean, it's not it's not that's not your personal karma, how you deal with it and how you how you feel about the person who sneezed in your face is your personal karma.
That's what your personal karma is.
So, OK, so here we have this idea that we started off with this wrong understanding.
We've created this mayhem and now we have to go back on it.
And our first attempt through the meditation is to let the heart manifest all its turbulences.
And we find that just by allowing it to do that, these turbulences just die away.
They begin to evaporate, you might say.
And that, of course, is not a short process.
That's going to be, I mean, restlessness doesn't go to the very end.
Not until that moment when we are fully liberated does restlessness leave us.
And it depends how you want to define restlessness.
The way I see it is that it's all these defilements, but now at such a low level that it's experienced by the person as a sort of discomfort, discomfort.
And of course, conceit, which is at the base of this relationship, the I am, I am me, doesn't go either.
So it's not as though we're ever going to be able to say, well, that's done.
You know, I'm finished with worrying about my dark side, you know, because it's always going to be there in some little way to the very end.
Now, our passage now is, first of all, to undermine that.
But then, of course, it's to develop the good heart.
It's to develop ourselves as beautiful people.
And the reason for that is because this is a manifestation of the Buddha within.
This is what we mean by the Dharma, by wisdom, by wisdom in action.
We mean, how does it manifest in the person?
And it manifests, of course, in all the virtues, and we can go through the perfections, as they're known.
But it also manifests in this sort of refinement of behavior.
You know, refinement of behavior.
And that's why there are all these little finickety rules in the monastic orders.
Now, on another tack...
We have to question what this more is, you see.
And here's the Buddha telling us what we actually need.
in order to live the spiritual life.
So don't confuse this with what we need in order to live the social life.
You know, like you need money for a bus, you need et cetera, et cetera.
But right at the base of our needs in order to live the spiritual life, we have these four requisites.
So I'll read them out as they come.
So wisely reflecting, I use the robe, so clothes, to ward off the cold, ward off the heat,
ward off the touch of flies, mosquitoes, wind, burning and creeping things, and only for the sake of modesty.
So there's no mention here of, you know, fashion shows.
I mean, you know, like what is the monk about town wearing at this moment?
You know, it's like it doesn't it doesn't come into the definition.
It's just straightforward.
You're wearing clothes to protect yourself.
Unfortunately, we've lost that connection with nature, which allows us to go around naked.
You know, like every other animal that we see here, they found ways of bearing with nature.
They can live in nature.
When we had that minus 21 up here during that very cold winter, we never had minus 21.
There were horses out in the field just standing like like statues close to each other, not against each other.
they bear I mean at night all day long and there was hardly any fodder though the farmer was bringing bales of fodder during the day but day after day I can't remember how long it lasted but it was a long time wasn't it at least a month wasn't it I remember that terrible winter and they didn't die they just stood in the cold and of course we have to well we need hot water bottles
So you can see there's a certain disconnect being a human being with nature.
But you can see here, that's all you actually need.
You only need the clothes to protect yourself from nature.
However, that might manifest.
You know, in the East, it's mosquitoes and stuff.
When it comes to alms food, you see, I use the alms food not for fun.
That kills it immediately, doesn't it?
not for pleasure uh this is indulgence i mean it's in a sense that's a wrong translation not not for fattening and not for beautification see but only for the maintenance and nourishment of the body for keeping it healthy for helping with the holy life thinking thus and this is what we say in a slightly different way at our meal times i will allay hunger without overeating so that i may continue to live blamelessly and at ease
So when you're taking food, you see, get down to that, you know, remind yourself of what you actually need, you see.
So it doesn't need to be really, really tasty.
It doesn't need to be particularly varied.
I mean, here, I think we go through every vegetable that is on earth by the end of the week.
And so many types of beans and so many types of pulses.
And I often think, well, I'm not so sure
That's particularly good for us because the body has to work at thinking, hold on, this is cauliflower.
This is broad beans, what am I going to do?
So the body has to keep manufacturing different enzymes to compete with the amount of food, all these different foods.
Whereas in the old days, it was just a chop and two veg.
And that was it.
And you had that every week.
You had fish with boiled potatoes, and that was it.
I remember that.
And all these drinks, millions of drinks.
Well, in the old days, it was just tea, wasn't it?
You want some tea?
You're not bothering.
That was the welcome, wasn't it?
Do you want a cup of tea?
You're not bothering.
I'd say, yeah, all right.
So it's good to remind ourselves about, you know, this refinement, about getting back to the basics of what we actually need.
And then we come to reflecting our lodgings where we live, you see.
So again, the Buddha is only concerned with warding off the cold.
ward off heat ward off the touch of flies mosquitoes wind winds burning and creeping things only to remove the danger from weather and for living in seclusion i mean that's that's the spiritual purpose of your of your dwelling uh the spiritual purpose of dwelling is to give you a place which is safe from the elements and marauding animals and things like that and quiet enough so that sometime in the day you can sit silently
And that's it.
That's the spiritual need for your house.
And then the final one is wisely reflecting.
I use the support for sick and medicinal requisites only to ward off painful feelings that have arisen and from the maximum freedom from disease.
And it doesn't actually say it here.
That's the actual verse we say.
But what we're supposed to be content with is fermented cow's urine.
Now, think on that.
Supposing you went to the doctor with pneumonia and he said, listen, the only thing I can offer you is fermented cow's urine.
I mean, would you say, what?
Or would you say, well, should I take it in spoonfuls or should I...
See, that's your basic line in the Ayurvedic medicine, you know, like fermented cows, you're right.
So it's like that also gives us a certain, what should we say, a certain...
a way of being with the NHS.
People complain about the NHS, but they don't want to lose it.
They're absolutely holding on to it.
That's the National Health Service.
They don't want to lose it by any means.
It's their thing.
Anybody, any politician who says they're going to do something about the NHS, everybody goes berserk.
But everybody complains.
It's not good enough.
It's not quick enough.
It's not this.
It's not that.
And what they need to do is contemplate fermented cows.
You're right.
And then they'd be very happy.
They'd say, oh my goodness, you know, all these machines and medicines, amazing.
So that's another way that we can look at our lives when we return, you see.
It's just like, what do I need, you see?
I remember these are the basic needs for the spiritual life.
I remember in the order, the Buddha sort of made it so that monks were completely dependent upon lay people.
I mean, you know, we can't touch money.
We're not supposed to touch money.
So people have to support us.
We can't cook, you see.
He made it very difficult to exit from society, even though he's always talking about seek seclusion, be on your own, get away from the madding crowd.
He's always talking about that.
But he wouldn't let you do this thing about, you know, getting your own little place out of the country and
like Sadi Panyan and getting on with it by yourself.
There always had to be this connection with lay people.
So obviously in lay life, you need much more than just a place where you can sit and so on.
But even so, you can take this as your absolute standard and then work up from that.
You know, just keep asking, well, what do you actually need?
What do you actually need?
So there are social needs, too.
I mean, if you're working, you can't turn up in rags.
So there's certain behaviors that society would ask of us, which would come under the idea of refinement.
So the next thing is to recognize this loop, this feedback loop that's in the eightfold path.
So mainly in the ten of arteries, well, it's pretty well universal, but we start with wisdom.
We start with trying to understand how we create suffering for ourselves.
And what this does is it creates a change in our attitudes.
That's why in our meditation we're always looking at the attitude which is driving the thought.
The thoughts themselves are only expressions.
So the wisdom is to realize that there are certain attitudes which are creating problems for us and certain attitudes which are creating happiness.
And we'll define happiness at some point.
So we talk about seeing these three characteristics, the impermanence of things.
That undermines attachment when you see the impermanence of things.
Why should you be so attached to this Ming vase?
You should give it away.
If you look at all your attachments, you can see that this is actually causing mental disturbance underneath.
And then there's the whole problem of dukkha, which is seeing the mechanism, this desiring, this way that we relate to things.
And again, it's to do with attachment.
Attachment, remember, is a psychological dependency on something.
for our happiness, which isn't under our control.
Either because it isn't under our control, it disappears, or somebody takes it, or it just is impermanent.
That's the end of that.
And the anatta is recognizing that this whole relationship begins with this sense of me.
And this me creates a little barrier.
Well, sometimes a big barrier.
There's me and you, you see.
And by letting go of the sharpness of that barrier, by perceiving how that barrier manifests, then we begin to move towards the opposite.
How does it manifest?
Well, it manifests, first of all, in selfishness.
That's your first manifest.
Every time, you know, these sneaky little selfishnesses, you know, where you take just that...
cake which is just a bit bigger than the others.
Everybody gets a piece, you know.
I'm here first.
You can see the struggle I go through every time I have to say food.
So, constantly letting go of the bigger piece of cake.
It's a misery.
So and then there's the business of acquisitiveness, selfishness.
So we've done that selfishness.
Then there's the business of these aversions, you know, petty little aversions, irritations, little bits of spite and all that sort of stuff.
And then there's this cruelty business where we get our own back and poke people in the eye and stuff like that.
And as we see that, this is actually, when we get into it as a bodily feeling, they're not pleasant at all.
Not pleasant at all.
And you think, well, you know, this feeling of selfishness is churning me up, this feeling
Feelings of aversion, of burning, you know, cruelty, so cold within me, things like that.
Being in the field, you feel the discomfort of them.
And, of course, you want to move away from that.
And the movement is towards the opposite, of course.
Selfishness, towards generosity, hatred to love and cruelty towards compassion.
And that movement is, as we've said during the week, it's a sublimation.
I mean, I rather like that word.
You know, I get it from chemistry, where some substances go from solid to liquid to air to gas, but some just go from solid to gas.
And the word for that, I believe, is sublimating.
So when we let go of a bit of hatred, it immediately sublimates.
into its opposite love it's not as though there's an in-between bit where there's a sort of hate love thing it just pops into the other into the other category you see and it's there as potential and it manifests in our actions and if you take any any uh any attitude which is unwholesome it will move towards his opposite
So the one I normally would centre on is loneliness.
Loneliness is a big thing in our society.
You know, the lack of extended families, elderly people, towards the positions which I'm moving myself, just stuck on their own.
are getting lonely.
So loneliness, of course, can lead to despair.
It's a feeling of being unloved, unwanted, not feeling worthy.
It's all that sort of rubbish that comes up inside us when we start feeling this loneliness.
And of course, there's a need for most people to have communication.
Just to talk to yourself in a mirror won't do.
And when you actually sit in the midst of that awful feeling and you're just staying with it and staying with it, you see, it begins to lessen away and it's beginning to sublimate.
So what does it move towards?
Solitude.
Solitude is being at peace with ourselves, just to be able to be completely happy on one's own.
So if you take any of these negative states and just work out what its opposite are, you can purposefully move towards the opposite through certain exercises.
And mainly the exercise is to stay with the unpleasant and wait for it to die away.
You might not see the opposite immediately, but at least just to wait for it to fade or to begin to fade.
And then one begins to see that there is an ending to this suffering.
There's an ending to these mental states.
And that all comes through our practice, through our practice of meditation.
Now, this is where it then begins to translate itself into what we do.
So, the right speech.
It's not just, you know, stop telling great big whoppers and things like that.
It's also to do with a refinement of speech, not wasting speech, not just talking for talking's sake.
A refinement of speech, not using coarse language.
Seeing the worthiness of really knowing what you're saying, of making it very deliberate.
Not just rabbiting on about something.
And then you get right action.
So this is normally defined as just moving away from all those five training rules that we have.
Not to kill, not to steal, etc.
But remember, as soon as you move away from those, you're moving towards the opposite.
So where now we've abandoned killing, we're now moving towards caring.
Caring for
Where we once might have not been so clever with our language, like exaggeration, you see.
Exaggeration is a sort of soft lie, you might say.
We're now being much more truthful, much more direct, much more simple.
Where we once used coarse language, we now try to phrase our language with a little bit of beauty, you know, like reading poetry, things like that.
And where there was useless speech, you know, you don't waste time on that.
But don't get confused between useless speech and the ordinary pleasantries of daily life.
In the monastic life where I was anyway, my monastery, which was a meditation monastery, nobody ever said good morning.
I mean, you turned up with your bowl and you were silent.
And then when you came out, nobody said, was that all right?
That was it.
It was in silence most of the time.
So when I went to live with my mother, after my father died, I stayed with her for a while.
One morning I came into the kitchen, you see, and began to say, when she turned around and said, well, good morning then.
And I thought, right, okay.
So from then on it was, how are you doing, mum?
Come on, give her a hug.
You know what I mean?
It's like...
And you forget these little pleasantries, which aren't useless speech.
They're just ordinary, so we say, simple human communication.
Sometimes you can make the mistake, I only made it once, where you think, well, you know, I've got to be sincere.
When I speak, I must be sincere.
So in the pleasantry of meeting people, say, and this happened to me when I was working at a college and a colleague was coming towards me and I was being sincere.
So I said to him, how are you?
And I said it in such a way that allowed him to spend 10 minutes telling me how he was.
I was late for the class and I thought, no, just how are you all doing?
How are you doing?
I'm all right.
So it's like you've got to temper what your ideas were, live and learn.
And then there's right livelihood.
And I think the key to right livelihood is the word service.
When we see our work as service, then of course everything seems to work for us.
So from a point of view of service, service demands a certain humility, by which I mean a reality about ourselves.
So when I offer my services to the company or to the workplace or to somebody in therapy or whatever I'm doing, when I'm offering my services, right, I'm open to the fact that they might not meet with the situation.
You know, they might not be good enough.
They might not be the right ones, you see.
But if it's come with the heart of service, that's not a problem.
No.
I remember once going for an interview.
I didn't get the job and I was in the waiting room and I was in the sitting room waiting to go in for the interview.
And at the end of the interview, I came out and I knew I'd botched it.
And I came out and I sat there and the guy and this man next to me said, I wonder what they're looking for.
See, we would say, I wonder who?
He was very wise.
It's not who they're looking for.
It's what you can offer a firm or your employees looking for.
And when you think, well, what are my skills?
What are my aptitudes?
That's what you're offering.
But if you put yourself in there, then there's always going to be a real downer.
You know, they don't want me.
But it's not a matter of wanting you.
They just want your skills.
You see what I mean?
And this also takes us into this whole area of ambition.
So a lot of people, when they come into this sort of teaching, think, oh, that's ego-driven.
I shouldn't be seeking power.
I shouldn't be seeking that.
But not if you're at service, because if you see your talents as being to the service of humankind, you have a duty to offer it.
so if you see yourself as being able to do that job you know whatever the prime minister or whatever you should do it because that's your duty to offer that service and that takes that that allows you to uh to grow because the buddha talks about um right livelihood as a as a place where you grow so if you think about the effect of the work you've done in your lives on your personality on your character
I mean, you can always tell somebody's been a policeman because they're always suspicious.
And the teacher always asks questions they can answer.
I mean, it's like it does affect you, you see.
Somebody who's in the caring professions, they affect the way they relate to people.
We shouldn't think so darkly about the armed forces as Buddhist, in the Buddhist, as a Buddhist or from a Buddhist point of view.
I know of one place who would not allow, it's a Buddhist center, who would not allow soldiers or anybody to do with the armed forces to enter into the property.
And I thought, well, you know, this is all a wrong understanding really.
Now, you might say, well, these people are trained to kill, right?
And they are, of course.
That's what they say.
Their job is to kill.
But it's to kill in the line of duty.
It's to kill in terms of protection.
Now, even monks can defend themselves.
We're allowed to defend ourselves.
And that's, of course, how the whole thing about Kung Fu came about.
The emperors of India, the emperors of China would either be Buddhist or they'd be anti-Buddhist, or they'd become Confucianism.
And so the Buddhist monks and the Buddhist community would find themselves being persecuted and the monks would have to flee and go into the hills, et cetera, et cetera.
So they had to find a way of defending themselves whereby their purpose wasn't to hurt the opponent, but to just to defend themselves.
And so this whole form of fighting was developed as a way of defending themselves, not as a way of attacking.
See?
And of course, you know, as you use the energy of the other to destroy the other's attack, as you know, as they pass by, just give them a quick rabbit shot and that's the end of it.
So there were, as we say, there were certain realisms about violence.
And I think it clarifies it if you make a distinction between force and violence.
force is the necessary energy you need to put right what is wrong violence is the same thing with anger with hatred with revenge with spite so for instance if you if you uh if you put a cup of coffee down on a table or tea and it falls off and you've got a choice you can either say oh yeah and wipe it up and put it back or you can start kicking yourself and getting upset with yourself
and banging the cup back on the table.
And that's the sort of differentiation which allows, you know, people to have countries to go in with armed intervention, you know, just to save the situation.
We've got lots of history, recent history, Rwanda for a start, where it was a failure to stop people murdering each other.
So there's a whole area there around livelihood.
Whatever we're doing is to recognize what qualities is my job doing?
What's it developing within me?
What are the qualities it's developing in me?
And then to see what qualities it's not developing.
But no job can develop all qualities.
And to make sure that somehow you either balance it or find some ways of developing those qualities.
Or indeed, there are certain qualities in a job which are overdeveloped.
Like I mentioned, the suspicions of my brother-in-law is a policeman.
So I know he's very suspicious.
So it's a case of recognizing that and using it for our benefit.
So here we have this
sense of refinement of our behavior undermining our unwholesome qualities and moving towards wholesome qualities the beautiful mind the beautiful heart and using our daily situations in order to do it and that's that's that's
of two things that we've been doing here relate directly to what we're doing in the in the world out there for instance when we're working it's care and attention it's making sure that we just stop for a moment to get the attitude right and we enter into the work with that attitude but we've got to keep mindful because these uh these uh defilements can slip in you know
So we start off being calm and with right attitude.
Before we know it, we're getting irritated.
In this case of stopping then and recognizing that and putting our attention on what we're doing.
When it comes to all the things that we enjoy in life, relationships, art, food, it doesn't matter what it is.
But at the end of it, to express our gratitude.
And then, once we've said thank you, you know, goodbye.
That's it.
It's gone.
Finished.
It's never to be repeated.
And that's the letting go of it.
When we are with people to remember that we're actually opening up to them.
We talked before about this
sense of I being a barrier see between me and you and what we need to do is to turn it into a sort of boundary and a boundary which is malleable it moves it's not it's not stiff it's not rock there's a lovely image I picked up from I think it was Ken Wilber actually I remember rightly where he talks about the beach so the beach sometimes is the sea and sometimes it's the land
And it's just being in that sort of relationship where you're coming from your position, but you're also seeing where the others are coming from.
And that gets rid of this idea of my view, my opinion.
And it moves us towards an idea of perspective.
And when you have your perspective, you can still maintain your perspective, but it includes them.
And so you don't get these violent opposites and you get a sense of ability to compromise because you're not creating these harsh sorts of definitions.
So there's lots of stuff around which you can read on daily life.
There's books aplenty, you know.
Catastrophe Living by Kabat-Zinn.
There's a lovely one by Jodo Beck, who's a Zen teacher.
There's lots of them.
And it's worth sort of, you know, picking them up and reading the occasional chapters and whatnot.
Because they, you know, these things, they do guide us in our practice.
But the important thing that we have to grasp is that the meditation is only really just part of the path.
It really is an important part.
It's the springboard.
I would say it's necessary.
But if I were talking a bit more, should we say subtly, I would say meditation isn't necessary.
What's necessary is mindfulness.
And that mindfulness, that being aware of what we're doing, is something we should try to maintain all the time.
It's very difficult, very difficult.
But meditation is a wonderful practice to sort of ground us and to get us to begin to work with all this subterranean stuff, you know, and to get us to see these qualities of anicca, dukkha and atta.
And all this feeds, it all feeds in, you see.
And not to be concerned about progress.
A lot of people, you know, well, I think we all get upset that, you know, I've been doing this for years and nothing's happened, right?
I think there's always a general feeling about that, you know.
And it's often, it's always to do with some sort of expectation about the rate of progress and expecting it to be much quicker than it is.
And why is it so slow?
Well, it's because we're lazy.
Sun Lung, the great Arahant in Burma, he had this very fierce meditation practice of breathing like an engine.
And you would breathe and breathe and breathe.
Like that, you see, until you were exploding with pain, and then the breath would stop, and it was as though the breath had pushed out all these defilements.
And that's the, I think that's the way he, I don't think he explains it like that, but that's the way I can only understand it working.
six weeks oh my goodness so that was from his first breakthrough he was just an ordinary farmer uneducated really and somebody told him how to do breathing meditation they must have told him this fast breathing which sounds more Hinduistic than Buddhist but
No, they tested him, the big monastic Sangha bosses tested him, and he himself declared himself didn't suffer.
I mean, nobody ever says that an Arahant, you know, you're in for people throwing stones and tomatoes at you, if you say that.
But he said he didn't suffer, you see.
And he was asked, he said, you know, like, you've made it so quickly, why is it that we can't?
He said, you're lazy.
you come here you work hard or so much you know then you give up then you go back and you know back to the old life get off not the tv get into it so it's up and down up and down but hopefully you know we do see uh improvements and i think rather than uh seeing our improvement in terms of you know insights
and stages, full of stages.
It's much better to think about how we're relating to people and how we're relating to the world and just finding a greater sense of contentment about our lives.
Wanting what we get and always getting what we want.
It's like turning things round and just get that sense of feeling of contentment in your reality.
So I can only hope my words have been of some assistance.
May you, by your fierce determination and continual practice, achieve liberation from suffering sooner rather than later.
It's always very weak, you know.
I never get the real punchy stuff.
I don't know whether you know this, but... Oh, what am I doing?
Heavens.
Hold on.